Transcription: Cassandra Chenut
Relecteur: eric vautier
Fake news.
Rarement un terme est rentré
aussi rapidement dans le langage courant.
On a l’impression
que tout le monde connaît ce terme.
Et pourtant, il n’est pas si vieux que ça.
Il est apparu dans une émission
de télévision américaine
qui s’appelle le Daily Show.
Et plus exactement dans une émission
de cette émission, The Onion.
C’était une émission pastiche
du travail journalistique,
et on ne cessait de parler de fake news.
Nous étions en 1999.
La personne qui a popularisé
les fake news, vous la connaissez,
il s’agit de Donald Trump.
Donald Trump, élu président
des États-Unis en 2016,
a même imaginé des Fake News Awards,
c’est-à-dire des récompenses
attribuées aux journalistes
qui écrivaient le maximum de fake news.
Les journalistes
n’étaient pas très heureux
et ceux du Washington Post,
un des grands quotidiens américains,
ont compté en 2018 le nombre de mensonges
proférés par Donald Trump :
15 par jour.
J’ai bien dit « par jour ».
Fake news,
ou, en bon français, infox,
il faut se mettre d’accord
sur ce que c’est exactement.
On en parle tellement à tort et à travers.
Fake news,
ce n’est pas uniquement une erreur.
C’est une erreur intentionnelle.
C’est quelqu’un qui a délibérément
fabriqué et qui diffuse
une information
pour vous tromper le cerveau.
Est-ce que c’est nouveau ?
Est-ce que ça ne remonte qu’à 1999
dans cette fameuse émission
The Onion dont je vous parlais ?
Eh bien, non.
Quand on remonte un peu dans le temps,
sans remonter à la préhistoire,
je suis remonté à la fin du XIXᵉ siècle
et je suis tombé sur ce monsieur :
Léo Taxil.
Et Léo Taxil, c’est un homme incroyable.
C’est l’embobineur professionnel.
C’est le fake new fait homme.
En fait, toute sa vie,
il a raconté des bobards.
Il en a fait son métier.
Il avait d’ailleurs fait fortune
avec des bobards.
Premier bobard d’ailleurs, son nom.
Son vrai nom,
c’est Gabriel [Jogand-Pagès].
Peu importe son vrai nom.
Au départ, il était anticlérical,
c’est-à-dire qu’il était contre les curés.
Et puis, il s’est converti.
Et puis il est devenu anti-maçons.
Anti-francs-maçons.
Et il a commencé à écrire dans la presse,
dans une presse
qu’il avait lui-même créée,
énormément de fake news sur le complot
de la franc-maçonnerie.
Le complot judéo-maçonnique,
c’est une fake news incroyable
qui a pesé à la fin du XIXᵉ siècle.
Tout était inventé.
Il allait même jusqu’à payer
des comédiens ou des comédiennes
pour venir alimenter les bobards
qu’il racontait à longueur de colonnes
dans ses journaux.
Tout était faux,
il a fini par se faire outer
et il a fini sa vie sous un autre pseudo :
Jeanne Savarin.
Il a écrit des guides pour les ménagères
afin de leur éviter de se faire arnaquer
en achetant leurs ustensiles.
Donc ça signe un peu le bonhomme.
Il y a un autre homme
dont il faut retenir le nom.
Il s’appelle Edward Bernays.
Edward Bernays est un Américain.
Nous sommes au tournant du XXᵉ siècle,
il a vécu très longtemps
et c’est un peu le père
de la propagande de masse.
C’est quelqu’un qui a utilisé
la psychologie pour influer au maximum
sur les populations.
C'est d'ailleurs le neveu
de Sigmund Freud.
Il a théorisé la propagande,
qu’on pourrait aussi appeler fake news,
et il a réussi,
dans la démocratie américaine,
des exploits incroyables sur la base
de la manipulation des cerveaux.
Son premier grand succès,
ça a été « I want you ».
Je veux que tu t’engages, toi,
jeune Américain, pour lutter en Europe
aux côtés des Français, des Anglais,
contre les Allemands.
Et il a réussi un retournement
de l’opinion publique
grâce à des propagandes et des affiches,
mais plein d’autres astuces,
au profit du président américain
qui l’avait engagé pour cette mission
alors que le président Wilson s’était
fait élire quelques années plus tôt
sur la promesse de non-ingérence des
États-Unis sur la guerre 14-18 en Europe.
Deuxième grand succès
absolument incroyable.
Il a permis à l’industrie du tabac
de gagner, de doubler son marché,
en faisant en sorte que
fumer soit considéré comme positif
pour les femmes,
alors que ça ne l’était pas.
Et pour ça, il s’est mis de mèche
avec des jeunes femmes
qu’on appelait les suffragettes,
c’est-à-dire des femmes
qui voulaient avoir le droit de vote,
qui ne leur était pas autorisé,
qui voulaient s’émanciper.
Et il a fait de la cigarette
un outil d'émancipation.
Et lors d’une grande manifestation
à New York des suffragettes,
certaines d’entre elles,
au-devant de la manifestation,
ont sorti leurs cigarettes
et se sont mis à fumer.
C'était scandaleux, mais ça a été vu
comme un outil d'émancipation.
La cigarette est donc devenue
le « Torches of Liberty »,
c’est-à-dire les torches de la liberté.
Et ça devenait donc ce que ça n'était pas.
Encore un succès de Edward Bernays.
Troisième et dernier exemple,
le fameux « American Breakfast »,
le petit déjeuner américain.
On croit que ça vient de toujours.
Mais non, c’est une construction,
c’est une manipulation du cerveau.
C’est une fake news en quelque sorte,
parce que c’est une construction
d’Edward Bernays avec l’industrie,
notamment l’industrie du bacon.
Donc l’œuf-bacon dont on croit
que c’est un héritage culturel,
en fait, c’est une manipulation du cerveau
à des fins de vente,
comme vous l’avez compris.
Vous avez maintenant compris
que les fake news ne sont pas
un phénomène nouveau
comme on pourrait le croire avec ce terme
qui a surgi il n’y a
qu’une vingtaine d’années.
Et pourtant, on en parle.
Et pourtant, ça nous mine
un petit peu l’esprit et le cerveau.
Et c’est devenu
un vrai problème de société.
Il y a trois grandes tendances globales
qui peuvent expliquer
la force des fake news.
D’une part, la complexité du monde.
On est rentrés dans une ère
d’une très grande complexité,
et le cerveau n’arrive plus
à comprendre où il en est
et a tendance à se réfugier
vers des options simples.
C'est une première tendance qui explique
la force des fake news.
Deuxième grande tendance,
c’est la démocratie et ses faiblesses.
La démocratie qui fonctionne mal,
qui ne provoque pas de débats,
qui ne permet pas d’aboutir
à des compromis,
qui ne permet pas un échange de parole,
mais plutôt une appropriation
de la parole par certains
et qui aboutit souvent
à du politiquement correct
ou à la pensée unique.
Et en contre-phénomène,
vous avez une défense
d’un certain nombre de personnes
qui veulent une vérité alternative
à cette pensée unique.
Deuxième grand mouvement
qui explique la force des fake news.
Troisième grand mouvement,
c’est ce que j’ai appelé
les multinationales surpuissantes.
C’est-à-dire que vous avez
des entités économiques
extrêmement puissantes
et qui peuvent manier à nouveau
le storytelling et la propagande de masse,
et qui peuvent vous manipuler le cerveau
à un point incroyable.
On ne s’en rend pas compte
quand on a des publicités sous le nez.
Mais quand on regarde
de vieilles publicités,
on en rigole.
Mais on a tort d’en rigoler
parce qu’on a peut-être
une moins bonne perception
des publicités actuelles.
Je vous ai donné deux exemples
de publicités anciennes.
Sur la gauche de l’image,
vous avez une actrice.
Une célèbre actrice américaine à qui,
apparemment, son coach de chant,
parce que c’était aussi une cantatrice,
a conseillé de fumer
pour s’éclaircir la voix,
c’est-à-dire l’inverse
de ce qu’il faudrait faire.
À droite, vous avez une autre publicité
qui vante les mérites des sodas
pour les jeunes enfants.
On connaît les ravages des sodas
et des boissons sucrées sur les enfants
dont la dentition n’est pas complète,
et aussi sur les adultes.
On a donc diffusé ce genre de publicité,
de propagande, de fake news.
Mais évidemment,
le phénomène des réseaux sociaux -
ça a été dit lors de la présentation -
est venu comme une vague, un tsunami,
pour expliquer les fake news.
Car l’accélération de la circulation
de l’information,
l’ampleur de cette information, cette
infobésité véhiculée par les fake news
engendrent beaucoup, beaucoup,
beaucoup d’effets pervers.
Je vous en ai laissé quelques-uns,
pas juste pour vous assener de chiffres,
mais 4 données pour vous faire comprendre
ce qu’il se passe
derrière les réseaux sociaux.
Déjà, des études ont montré
qu’une information fausse,
une fake news, avait tendance à circuler
six fois plus vite
qu’une information réelle.
Pourquoi ça ?
Parce qu'elle touche à l'émotion.
Et quand on est ému, on ne pense plus,
mais on partage.
Une autre étude toute récente a montré
que 20% des vidéos de Tiktok
étaient fausses, étaient
des constructions, des fake news.
Vous allez me dire, il reste 80%,
mais moi je m’intéresse aux 20%.
C'est énorme.
50% des partages que vous faites, que
nous faisons tous sur les réseaux sociaux,
se font sans qu’on n’en connaisse
la source.
C’est-à-dire qu’on ne vérifie pas
d’où elle vient.
On pense que l'information est bonne,
donc on la diffuse.
Et enfin, 1% des détenteurs
de comptes sur les réseaux sociaux
produisent 33% des informations.
Vous voyez cette distorsion ?
Ça veut dire que sur les réseaux sociaux,
les gens qui veulent vous induire
en erreur sont très bien organisés
et peuvent avoir une influence colossale
par rapport au nombre qu’ils représentent.
Fake news.
Demain, vous avez les deep fake news.
Cette histoire n’est pas finie.
Et ça va s’intensifier.
Qu’est-ce qu’un deep fake news ?
C’est un fake news plus approfondi,
plus sophistiqué,
grâce aux nouvelles technologies.
Les nouvelles technologies qui vont, grâce
à des lectures optiques de votre visage,
grâce à l’analyse du mouvement
de vos lèvres,
pouvoir reproduire soit une image,
soit un discours,
en reprenant la texture de votre voix
comme si c’était vrai.
Sur la droite, vous avez Mark Zuckerberg
à qui on essaie de montrer
que Facebook peut avoir
des effets négatifs.
Et donc c’est une image qui représente
potentiellement le deep fake news.
Si vous voyiez le discours qu’on lui
fait tenir, vous seriez horrifiés.
Et sur la gauche, vous avez un fake news
utilisé par une association,
qui s’appelle Solidarité SIDA,
qui a truqué des images
de Trump un peu à contrepied,
Donald Trump disant « AIDS is over » -
« Le SIDA n’existe plus »,
il n’y a plus de problème de SIDA.
Ça a été grandement
reproché à l’association
puisque c’était une sorte de fake news,
utilisée certes pour la bonne cause,
mais qui a embrumé les cerveaux.
On va prendre un exemple
pour vous montrer l’ampleur
de la difficulté qui est devant nous :
le scandale Cambridge Analytica.
On est en 2014.
Cette société récupère
87 millions de profils Facebook
qui avaient été utilisés par un chercheur
qui avait dealé avec Facebook
à des fins de recherche.
Il revend ces profils à cette société
qui, fort de toutes ces données,
arrive à croiser ces données récupérées
avec des données électorales
et permet de truquer les messages
d’hommes ou de femmes politiques
en fonction de ce croisement.
Je m’explique.
Si vous êtes catalogué
avec tel ou tel profil,
telle ou telle tendance de vote,
tel ou tel profil électoral,
vous allez, grâce au croisement
des données,
recevoir un message différent
du même homme
ou de la même femme politique.
Et donc quelque part,
le mensonge sera parfait
puisque le message
sera adapté à votre profil.
On estime que le scandale
Cambridge Analytica
a favorisé la victoire de Trump en 2016
et a favorisé la victoire du Brexit.
C’était la même année, je pense.
Ça s’est joué à quelques centaines
de milliers de voix,
et ce scandale a sans doute
influé en faveur du Brexit.
Facebook a d’ailleurs été condamné
pour délivrance interdite de ces données
à cinq milliardsde dollars d’amende.
Vous allez me dire :
« Tout ça est bien triste,
mais comment on va faire
pour se désintoxifier le cerveau ? »
Eh bien, c’est compliqué.
C’est compliqué parce qu’on est tous
portés par des biais cognitifs,
c’est-à-dire qu’on a une façon
de penser très particulière
et qui ne nous empêche pas
de tomber dans les pièges des fake news.
Je vous en ai énuméré quelques-uns.
Le premier, c’est la paresse.
On est tous paresseux et notre cerveau,
lui aussi est paresseux.
C’est-à-dire qu’il préfère toujours
postuler qu’une information est vraie
plutôt que de faire l’effort
de vérifier par nous-même.
Deuxième biais, c'est ce qu'on appelle
le biais de confirmation.
Plus l’information est relayée,
plus on pense qu’elle doit être vraie,
sinon elle ne serait pas
autant relayée et répétée.
Troisième biais, le biais de renforcement.
On a toujours tendance
à aller chercher les informations
qui valident ce qu’on pense déjà.
C'est beaucoup plus simple.
Enfin, un biais de représentativité.
Je vous en ai mis un bel exemple.
En gros, c'est le jugement que tout un
chacun a à partir de quelques bribes,
quelques éléments
qui ne sont pas forcément fondés,
mais qui font démonstration.
Je vous lis la bulle, le dessin de
Philippe Geluck qui représente le Chat.
Sur la bulle de gauche,
je vais m’approcher
parce que je n’arrive pas à bien lire.
« J’aimerais tout de même savoir
comment il se fait que le Pape
se sente obligé de démissionner. »
Bulle de droite :
« Pile poil au moment où éclate
le scandale des lasagnes au cheval. »
Et il conclut : « Tout ça ne doit pas
être très catholique. »
Okay ?
Donc là, évidemment, c’est de l’humour.
On rassemble des éléments épars
et on se fait sa démonstration.
C’est le biais de représentativité.
Avec tout ça, je ne vous ai pas rassurés
et donc je n’ai pour vous qu’une solution.
Et cette solution - retenez ce mot,
je trouve que c’est un très beau mot,
je l’ai découvert pour vous ce soir -
c’est la zététique.
La zététique, c'est l'art du doute.
C’est le souci de toujours
remonter aux sources,
de vérifier son info.
Ça vient du grec ancien.
Je vous ai proposé un diplôme de zététique
parce que la seule solution
pour contrer les fake news,
c’est de changer sa tournure d’esprit
en adoptant l’art du doute,
en adoptant l’esprit critique.
C’est déjà un premier pas pour vous
d’assister à cette soirée TEDx,
« L’art de tromper les cerveaux »,
car je pense que ce soir,
vous ressortirez plus fort
pour contrer les fake news
que vous ne l’étiez en arrivant.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)